okay let's go ahead and unpack this comment
because you started it by calling my children in general spawn
so you just wanted to humanize
you even admit that it's derogatory
but you don't care because you were a jerk who's happy being a jerk
and that's fine
I wanna touch on the second part of this conversation
which is that um
bad child behavior is an epidemic in this country
and that teachers are even commenting it
because I have also seen all those videos
and I am also a parent within the community
and I've seen all sorts of parenting and all sorts of the results of it
so let's come have a conversation
because I would agree that a lot of the
what we're gonna call bad parenting
that other people seem to believe creates bad behave children
and I don't like using the word bad
but just for the sake of this argument
you know what I'm talking about
it's usually permissive parenting
because authoritarian parenting makes kids afraid of adults
permissive parenting is a lack of boundaries and structure
the path of least resistance
those the parents that you see ignoring their children
climbing the walls at an establishment and you're thinking
don't they see this
can't they do something about that
but whereas teachers are making this content
because they would like to provide a more conducive
and safe learning environment for the children that are under their charge
and a better work environment
for themselves
um you're just worried about your own individual comfort
so we're not gonna worry about that
because I don't care about your individual comfort
what I do care about is children and parents and teachers
because when we notice there's a problem
when we acknowledge that there is an issue
and that permissive parenting is probably the issue
we have to look at the why
if you actually wanna solve anything and be constructive
so why is permissive parenting becoming such a big thing
it's not that this is just a random group of individuals who just decided
you know what
I just don't care what my kids do whatever
no it is because setting boundaries
holding expectations of parenting thoughtfully has a
an excessive amount of energy
resources and effort needed to do that
something that societally we do not make easy for parent
most households right now are two working income parents
which means parents are getting home at the end of the day already exhausted
already depleted
probably working more than they should for less than they're being paid for
dealing with increasing behaviour problems
because of access to technology and social media
as well as a society that sets up absolutely no safety nets
for our parents and children
has no subsidized child care
no government aid really for parents in the form of maternity
paternity healthcare
we also have school systems who are not equipped to follow things like 504 and IEPs correctly
for kids that do have higher needs
and then on top of it we have parents that are increasingly isolated
we have communities that do not bond together
that do not create a village
what we have is a society that wants to shame and blame like you
because what is good for parents
what is good for children
and what is good for society as a whole
is for parents and children to be out in a social setting
with the mentality of a collective village
all looking out for these kids um
but instead so that's a perfect storm
it's a perfect storm of overworked
underserved socially ostracized people with children
and that's assuming two parent households
of which we're not even acknowledging the immense amount of energy
and exhaustion
and work that is put on the shoulder of single parents
so they take the path of least resistance
but instead of making this an individualistic problem
this is a one parent who's just a bad parent
we could actually look at how we collectively handle children pregnancy families
and make a society that would be conducive to collective parenting
to respectful parenting
to parenting with consciousness and effort
cause the reality is parents can't do it alone
they were never meant to
and they definitely were never meant to do it under the strains of capitalism
so if you really give a shit
let's talk about the why